l'art de la controverse ce n'est pas
seulement l'art de manier les armes de
la rhétorique ce n'est pas seulement
savoir maîtriser le langage c'est aussi
savoir provoquer des émotions c'est
aussi savoir exciter l'adversaire le
faire sortir de son calme de faire
sortir de sa raison le rôle donné par
les romantiques à l'appartenance face à
l'idéologie d'un homme des Lumières des
conçu comme son propre fondement et bien
ce discours
le mythe selon lequel le débat
intellectuel reposerait seulement sur
l'affrontement d'idées pures c'est
quelque chose que n'importe quelle
personne ayant pratiqué le débat ne peut
plus croire l'expression de nos idées
est toujours influencée par nos émotions
or il n'y a rien de plus volatile il n'y
a rien de plus influençable qu'une
émotion